all right hold on that's the way to do
it that's how we do in the streets I'm
so really from yesterday watching this
film
it is absolutely amaze I can't wait for
girls to watch for you too you have two
girls and to have a film like this a
Polynesian princess on the Disney roster
and it's huge it's you and you know I
recognize I didn't know it when I
accepted the role and when we talked
about it but I know it now after I've
seen the movie is this it's a
once-in-a-lifetime stuff like this
doesn't come around I'm lucky that it
came around once and just the
opportunity not only as a proud
Polynesian I'm half black half Samoan
but then also it's the opportunity to
showcase our culture to the world in in
a positive way in a meaningful way in a
truthful way and in a cool way in a fun
way and I have two girls one's 15 ones
11 months a baby and then as a teenager
too so it's very it's beautiful I got a
whole new understanding about tattoos as
well I got this last night don't show it
to you because there's a lot of
similarities between you two the mini
Maui he kind of represents his wisdom
and strength even right here you have a
warrior head as well correct
does that give you wisdom and strength
and does it help you
well the tattoo is very meaningful so in
Polynesian culture our tattoos carry a
lot of meaning and they they carry a lot
of what we call mana which means power
and spirit so yes so this is uh this is
my mana where's your mana the entire
tattoo is my mana very specifically the
over my heart okay because it's a face
of a warrior right and it's my mana it's
my strength the tattoo originates up
here it's called Putin mana which is the
strength of a flower spirit of a flower
a power of a flower meaning I was raised
by women yes lift them respect them and
love them
don't thank too much
that's a good thing so yes so the
tattoos mean a lot and it was really
cool putting the character together in
terms of the animation yeah
and especially adding the tattoos those
cool element now you are demigod yes you
are I have to ask when are you gonna be
People's Sexiest Man Alive of 2016
ah that I don't know you don't know come
on you know I don't know you can wink at
me I don't know nothing he knows we're
gonna find out soon now going to a
Hawaii in December I know you're
shooting their right minds good we're
gonna do a workout together I'm gonna be
gone I just I just left them we need to
have make it happen what yes the working
on she's crazy work out we need to work
out together pointing button needs you
do a video what are you wanna kill me so
I'm just going to visit and I want to
ask you because I know that I like is
pigeon yeah the three words I shouldn't
use when I'm in Hawaii shouldn't you
shouldn't use okay uh hey hey yo yo
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah love you